mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
suppose a multiplied by the square root
of a
plus b multiplied by the square root of
b is equal to 183
also suppose that b multiplied by the
square root of a
plus a multiplied by the square root of
b is equal to 182.
if a and b are real numbers what is the
value of 9 over
5 multiplied by the sum of a and b
[Music]
i thank davis from india for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
to solve this problem we will make two
substitutions
first suppose that the square root of a
is equal to x
this means a is equal to x squared
next suppose that the square root of b
is equal to y
meaning b is equal to y squared
we will carefully make these
substitutions into the first two
equations
do this part slowly because you don't
want to make a mistake right when you're
starting the problem
now ultimately we need to calculate the
sum of a
and b and that is equal to x squared
plus y squared
so let's work out x squared plus y
squared to do that we'll simplify these
equations
x multiplied by x squared is equal to x
cubed
y multiplied by y squared is equal to y
cubed
the second equation will then become x y
squared
plus x squared y and that's equal to 182
from here recall that the cube of the
sum
of x and y is equal to x cubed
plus y cubed plus three multiplied by x
y squared
plus three multiplied by x squared y
we'll factor a three from the last two
terms
from here we can substitute that x cubed
plus y
cubed is equal to 183
we can then substitute from the second
equation that x y
squared plus x squared y is equal to
182.
this allows us to calculate that x plus
y the quantity cubed
is equal to 729 which is equal to 9
cubed now since
x is equal to the square root of a and y
is equal to square root of b
and a and b are real numbers we can take
the cube root of both sides
to get that x plus y is equal to 9.
from here we'll use this fact along with
the second equation
to further continue our calculation
now in the second equation we're going
to take a look at x y squared
we'll write it as x multiplied by y
multiplied by y
then x squared y is the same thing as
x multiplied by x multiplied by y
now notice we have an x y in both of
these terms
so we can factor out so this will be
equal to x
y multiplied by the sum of y and x
and that's of course the same thing as
the sum of x and y
but we know that x plus y is equal to 9
so we can substitute
here we thus solve for the value of
x y it'll be equal to 182 over nine
now we recall that x plus y the quantity
squared
is equal to x squared plus y squared
plus two multiplied by x
y from the first equation we can
calculate
that x plus y the quantity squared is
equal to 9 squared
and that's equal to 81. so we can
substitute that into the left-hand side
of the equation
then we know the value of x y so we'll
substitute that into the equation
we can now solve for the value of x
squared plus y squared
we'll simply simplify in this equation
and we'll get that x squared plus y
squared is equal to 365 over nine
now recall that a is equal to x squared
and b is equal to y squared
so this is equal to a plus b
we want to evaluate 9 over 5 multiplied
by the sum
of a and b so it'll be 9 over 5
multiplied by 365 over 9.
the nines will cancel out so we're left
with 365
over 5 and that's equal to 73
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions
where we solve the world's problems one
video at a time
you